ich danke sehr geehrte frau präsidentin
göring eckardt werden herr bundeskanzler
scholz sehr verehrte damen und herren
abgeordnete
gäste anwesen der journalisten
sehr verehrtes deutsches volk ich wende
mich an euch nach drei wochen der
unerwarteten angriffs der russischen
truppen in die ukraine nach acht jahren
krieg im osten unseres landes im bass
ich wende mich an euch als russland
bombardiert unsere städte und zerstört
alles was in der ukraine da ist das sind
wohnviertel krankenhäuser schulen
kirchen alles mit paketen mit luft
bomben mit atelier
in drei wochen sind
sehr viele ukraine gestorben tausende
die besatzer haben 108 kinder getötet
mitten in europa bei uns im jahre
ich wende mich alles sieht nach vielen
treffen verhandlungen erklärungen und
bitten nach den schritten zur
unterstützung die die die manche sind zu
spät gekommen sind und nach sanktionen
die vielleicht zu wenig sind um diesen
krieg zu stoppen und nachdem wir gesehen
haben
wie viel ihre unternehmen noch in
russland geblieben sind im land das euch
einfach ausnutzt und manche länder und
den krieg zu finanzieren
in drei wochen des krieges in für unser
leben für unser freiheit haben wir uns
überzeugt daran dass wir gespürt haben
und dass sie vielleicht nicht alle
merken aber
sie befinden sich irgendwie wieder
hinter der mauer nicht berliner mauer
aber mitten in europa wo gibt es
freiheit und dieses mauer ist stärker
mit jeder bombe die auf unser wurden in
der ukraine
fällt bei jeder entscheidung die nicht
getroffen wird und den frieden obwohl es
uns helfen konnte wann ist das geschehen
sehr verehrter politiker sehr verehrtes
deutsches volk warum ist das wirklich
wir haben immer gesagt dass most ring 2
ist eine waffe und vorbereitung auf den
großen krieg und wir haben als antwort
bekommen dass es wirtschaft wirtschaft
wirtschaft und das war ein cent für die
neue mauer wir haben euch gefragt was
soll ukraine tun um mitglied der nato zu
sein und die garantierte sicherheit zu
bekommen wir haben die antwort gehört es
gibt keine solche entscheidung bis jetzt
auf dem tisch und in der nächsten zeit
wird das nicht gut das war dritte das
war traurig für uns an diesem tisch und
auch jetzt zögern sinn bei dem beitritt
der ukraine der europäischen union wenn
offen gesagt für manche ist das die
politik und in wirklichkeit ist das ein
für eine neue als wir gebeten haben um
präventive aktionen wir wandten uns
andere hob an kleine starten wir wandten
uns an euch und
damit der aggressor spürte dass sie
kraft sind aber wir spielten die
verzögerung wir haben denn widerstand
verspürt wir haben kapiert sie wollen
die wirtschaft wirtschaft wirtschaft
weiter fortführen und auch jetzt die
maschinen zwischen meinestadt.de
dieser stand
brachte zu uns den krieg und das wird
auch wie wenn man eine mauer sein und
sie sehen nicht was sich hinter dieser
mauer versteckt das ist eine mauer
zwischen den menschen in europa und
deswegen verstehen nicht alle dass wir
heute was wir heute erleben ich wende
mich an euch im namen aller ukraine und
ich wende mich an euch aus mariupol die
einwohner der stadt die von russischen
truppen blockiert wurden und praktisch
dem boden gleich machen vernichten alles
was da ist alles und alle die das sind
hunderttausend menschen
dann buchen sie jeden tag 24 stunden
ohne wasser ohne elektrizität ohne essen
ohne verbindung wochen wie lang die
russischen truppen unterscheiden nicht
zwischen den zivilen
soldaten zwischen den zivilen objekten
und betrachten als zielscheibe alles
in der stadt wo
das schauspielhaus wo tausende von
menschen saßen das gestern gesprengt
wurde auch ein geburtshaus auch viele
andere zivil häuser die zerstören alles
den ganzen tag
24 stunden und sie lassen keine
humanitäre güter bei uns ist die stadt
blockiert
55 tage wird vom basiert damit keine
rettung für unsere menschen kommt das
können sie alles sehen wenn sie uns
unterstützung und wenn sie die mauer
etwas verschieben damit das ist also
eine luftbrücke könnte man machen damit
der himmel
sicher ist jetzt in unserem land wenn
wir können auch keine brücke keine
luftbrücke machen als die russischen
raketen und bomben die ich wende mich an
euch im namen der ukrainer der eltern
ukraine die den krieg überlebt haben und
die auch vor 80 jahren auch die
besatzung
erlebt hat die bühne ja die das ist ein
baden
jahres besuchte uns im letzten jahr
präsident steinmeier und der verehrte
diese 30 diese tragödie und jetzt schlug
dort die russische rakete ein und das
ist in die ehemalige ruine landete
wieder eine recht
also wieder nach 80 jahren ich wende
mich an
ich niemals wiederholen und es ist alles
wenn man das nichts verkörpert dann ist
das nicht wert und wieder versucht man
in europa das ganze volk zu vernichten
warum
worum unwissend wegen ich wende mich an
euch im namen unserer soldaten die
unsere werte verteidigt unser land und
auch die werte von denen wir oft
sprechen hier in europa hier in europa
ist hier menschen können frei leben und
und wir können unser menschen wollen
frei leben und nicht einem staat
unterwerfen dass unser land für das
eigene heldt wir können das nicht warum
die staaten hinter dem ozean sind jetzt
näher stehen als ihr weil das die mauer
ist das ist die mauer
und wir merken diese mal nicht aber wir
schlagen uns an dieser mauer solange wir
kämpfen darum das eigene volk zu
erhalten
politiker deutsches volk ich danke jedem
der uns unterstützt ich danke
einfachen menschen die aufrichtig den
ukrainer bei euch helfen der
journalisten die ihre arbeit jährlich
vergeben und zeigen das ganze böse was
russland zu uns gebracht hat und auch
dem deutschen dem deutschen business
geschäftsleute der die moral her stellte
als die wirtschaft wirtschaft wirtschaft
hier danken der politiker die als ich
versuchen diese mauer zu brechen die
di di di di di und
unterstützen die fast der punkte
sanktionen und die kinder zu retten
kann direkt gerettet werden der frieden
in der ukraine der frieden in europa das
wir danken den menschen die nicht zögern
russland von
abzuschalten und die verstehen das
embargo notwendig ist dass es notwendig
ist dass die unter bilde dir diesen
kriegs und ukraine wird in der
europäischen union sein ich bin dankbar
allen die alle wissen
dass sie das es gibt immer mehr
verantwortung und tapferkeit wenn es um
die rettung der menschen gehe es ist
fällt uns schwer
ohne unterstützung der welt zu leben
ohne eure hilfe ukraine und europa zu
verteidigen ohne dass das sie tun was
sie in der lage sind zu tun damit sie
sich nicht schämen nach diesem krieg
nach dem zerstörten zum zweiten mal nach
80 jahren nach der zehn bomben
zerstörten stadt
in 80 jahren nachdem viele menschen
getötet und gefoltert wurde zum zweiten
mal was was ist wird die historische
verantwortung die immer noch nicht
gezeigt wurde und bereut wurde was vor
80 jahren geschah und das was jetzt
wieder die mauer und das wird immer eine
mauer seien die immer mehr verlangen
wird ich werde mich an euch und ich
erinnere mich an euch dass die das tun
ohne dass europa nicht überleben wird
und nicht ihre werte bewahren will
früherer
präsident der vereinigten staaten von
amerika
regeln sagte einmal in berlin
zerstört diese mauer und ich kann jetzt
sagen ich möchte euch sagen herr
bundeskanzler scholz zerstörung sie
diese mauer geben sie zeigen sie den
führer in deutschland in lieder der das
verdient und ihren nachkommen werden nur
stolz auf sie sein unterstützen sie uns
unterstützen sie jeden ukraine
bitte helfen sie uns helfen sie uns
diese
zu stoppen
ich danke sehr
[Applaus]